okay i'm feeling good about the three
minutes games
um let's accept what another one
uh boited zuk from germany
and um good thing about playing c6 on
the first move is then you can
you can pre-move um
d5 on the next and let's play the old
i could be wrong i think it's the winner
gambit
i could be very wrong i i think that is
the case
uh and uh yeah i usually take an
e5 there um
there have been some famous games there
like kasparov one
game against nikolic with white very
nicely i think that was with
with the pawns in c4 and c6 so it's not
exactly the same
usually like that's a gambit we usually
end up
giving the pawn back with uh with a
somewhat better position
which is the way you should very often
treat gambits here
uh i've once again essayed a an early um
an early h5 but um in these structures
it's very very positionally sound
and frankly my opponent has just played
a little too passively here
um and uh yes um
well basically here
i'm going to say white's position is
lost um
positionally speaking because you have
the word structure
i have a fairly easy plan of attacking
on the king's side
and you don't have any kind of play and
i would say in games between
very top players here
you would be absolutely desperate as
white
like this is a french structure gone
horribly horribly wrong um
and it it just goes to show that
you can very often in the opening play
um
very normal logical moves and still end
up
so much worse um because you're playing
too passively
and you don't have um don't have a
don't have a real plan uh now b4
this doesn't really do anything and
i could double rooks here um rook c7
followed by
by um uh by rook c8 and it's
becoming increasingly clear that i just
have an advantage across the
entire board now after um
yeah after rook f1 an important pawn
falls here as well
uh and this um spells
spells doom for white bishop h1
that's probably the best try but i'll
just um
i'll just give give a check um
and now that i've won the h pawn uh my
own pawn is just
running down the board very very quickly
and um yeah there's just no hope for
for for white here um there's not a
single weak point in my position my
pieces are perfectly coordinated and um
yeah i can basically win as i please uh
i'll take on c1 i think queen to b5
always nice to try and finish with some
little tactics
you can go queen a2 or queen b2 though
in order to
uh prevent the mate that was threatening
but he didn't
um and allowed mate with brooks he
wanted
and and
queen e2 okay uh yeah once again the
lesson on
what can happen when you play all very
very decent moves but you play a little
bit
too passively